on va passer au deuxième thème de cette
émission la loi Love Me de son nom de
code loi d'orientation de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur qui prévoit
15 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour la police et la gendarmerie en
défendant son texte Gérard Darmanin
s'est targué d'avoir le soutien des
sénateurs écoutés le Sénat a suivi le
gouvernement alors qu'on sait que
naturellement le Sénat ne suis pas
forcément le gouvernement dans une quasi
unanimité politique
s'inspirant je crois de la position que
nous avons toutes et tous pour la
sécurité de nos concitoyens adoptant des
abonnements de tous les bancs
nous avons à 27 voix près fait voter un
texte qui prévoit 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur cinq ans et qui je
crois est très attendu par l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens et par les agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur
alors Gérard Darmanin se félicite
d'avoir beaucoup de soutien des
sénateurs des sénateurs et aussi des
députés de LR et aussi de beaucoup de
députés mais pas forcément des bancs de
gauche vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec beaucoup de dispositions notamment
l'aggravation des peines encourues en
cas d'outrage sexiste elle est fi a voté
contre pourquoi mais en fait le problème
c'est que c'est pas en augmentant à
chaque fois les amendes qu'on arrive à
résoudre le problème vous savez c'est un
texte de droite donc c'est logique qui
soit soutenu par la droite il y a
notamment un aspect totalement
scandaleux dans ce texte c'est le
recours aux amandes forfaitaires
délictuels ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup ça
nous inquiète beaucoup il y en a
bataillé à l'Assemblée nationale
là-dessus pour les petits délits oui il
faut savoir qu'au départ il voulait
mettre en place 3400 délits en amende
pour faire se perd des rituels ça veut
dire que quand vous avez une amende
forfaitaire forfaitaire délictuel c'est
dur à dire vous ne passez pas devant un
juge donc vous avez pas le droit à la
défense un avocat au contradictoire il
n'y a pas d'individualisation de la
peine et en plus le gouvernement en
commission des lois Emmanuel
monsieur Darmanin et le groupe
Renaissance ont ajouté des AFD si vous
avez des lycéens majeurs qui
occupent leur lycée par exemple ou si
vous avez des entraves à la circulation
c'est à dire l'occupation de rond-point
ça veut dire que à quelques semaines de
la grande bataille sur les retraites ou
le gouvernement s'est pertinemment qui
va y avoir une mobilisation d'ampleur
qu'on ne se proje régressif de retraite
à 65 ans il crée des amendes forfaitaire
délictuelles de 500 à 1600 euros pour
criminaliser finalement les lycéens qui
pourraient occuper leur lycée en guise
de protestation ou bien des écologistes
qui
occupent des des voies contre l'inaction
climatiques et on l'a vu récemment ça
serait aussi des amants de santé tel
forfaitaire délictuelles qu'aurait pu se
prendre les gilets jaunes donc à
l'approche de la grande bataille sur les
retraites on trouve ça vraiment une
dérive autoritaire extrêmement
problématique pour nos droits nos
libertés fondamentales
[Musique]